- Well, now it's time for our pick from
"The Little Yellow Book,"
that's our curated list of stuff I love
that I always wanna share with you.
We refresh it every single
week on our website.
And today's pick is a greeting
card that you can grow
in the ground.
Thoughtful human cards.
I love these so much.
So, they're plantable.
They have seeds in them.
And they come.
- [Co-host] Aww.
- [Drew] One for every occasion.
I really like this one.
We're all rooting for you,
it's very like, sporty.
And then when you're done,
you crumple it or cut it up,
and you stick it
in some soil.
And not only is it zero waste,
but then you can actually
cultivate a little life out of it.
(audience clapping)
- [Co-Host] That is so cute.
- I know!
- I wonder if it's, this
would be great too for like a
wedding invite or something.
You know what I mean-
- Yes!
You could invite someone
on to your wedding.
And then,
(participant laughs distantly)
they could stick it
somewhere and grow something
out of it.
(co-host laughs)
- Well, they can stick
that text somewhere,
is what they can do-
- [Drew] That's exactly right!
(bright music)